Joining me today is the host of Tucker
Carlson,
tonight on Fox News,
now a New York Times best selling author
with his new book ship of fools,
Tucker Carlson.
Welcome to the Rubin.
I am glad to have you here,
my friend.
I'm glad to be here.
I love this.
I don't know that anyone that has ever
walked in here and been more impressed
by the rubrics and television so I know
what this is and it's just the coolest
thing I've seen in a long time.
Are you jealous?
Are you joking?
Yes,
I'm jealous.
You have millions and millions of views,
a massive staff,
but I don't have the control that you
have,
which is wonderful.
Yeah,
control.
All right,
so speaking of control,
I have only one goal for the next hour,
which is to some point say something so
ludicrous that you stare at me with that
face where I make do that.
Where did the face come?
It's totally everyone the memes that
come in with that,
but the funny thing is when,
I mean that's just my face at rest,
which is golden retriever,
like I'm a mouth breather and when I
first started this show,
um,
I got complaints about it internally and
the idea was,
it's too embarrassing.
Click a moron,
but I can't stop.
I can't help myself.
So I'm not as super self aware person.
I'm not a mirror user for example,
because if you work in TV and you become
really self conscious,
it destroys you and makes you insecure.
So I just am trained after 20 years not
to think about the way I look and I
didn't even know that I look like a
moron,
but I do and I'm not changing.
Well,
I know you're not guessing because even
just now when you were in the green room
and my girl is putting makeup on your,
you,
you sat there for literally two seconds.
You were like,
don't do anything.
You didn't even look at the mirror.
You're looking at me and you can go
crazy.
As you know in TV,
if you start to think about how other
people perceive you,
you just drowned in lake me,
you know,
and I don't want that.
All right.
So I'm glad to have you here for a
couple of reasons.
We're going to get into the book and
obviously we're kind of simpatico on
what I think are the big issues of the
day to free speech,
all that stuff.
But I will be totally honest with you,
years ago when I first saw you on a
crossfire on CNN,
I was not a fan.
Now I was alone in that I thought here's
this bow tie wearing guy who was
seemingly kind of smug and whatever.
And I was a lefty at the time.
So,
so we were really polar opposites
politically,
but everything has shifted enough that,
that we are kind of allies now.
And I actually think that's Kinda cool.
So before we do anything else,
tell me about little Tucker Carlson.
People know about Tucker Carlson,
that eviscerates socialists all day.
What was that like as a kid?
Yeah,
southern California.
And um,
we lived in studio city and I mean I
think I've always been the same
anti-authoritarian for the individual
against the group.
Um,
I,
I hate bullies,
I hate being bullied more than anything.
And so if I find myself,
and I've always been this way in a
scenario where everyone is forced to
sort of,
not in bovine agreement about something,
my instinct is always to be the one guy
who was like,
no,
and I'm so,
I haven't changed at all.
The particulars of my political beliefs
have changed because America has changed
so dramatically.
I'm 49,
so in the last 40 years it's become a
different country and a lot of the
things that I thought would work haven't
worked.
A lot of the things I thought were not
threatening turned out to be
threatening.
So,
you know,
my views have changed,
but my instincts have remained
consistent over time.
Were you always political or were your
parents?
I was always political.
Yeah.
Well I was always interested in history
and my father was a non conformist,
I would say.
I mean that's an understatement.
And his baseline position was just
because everybody says it doesn't mean
it's true in the answers to the way,
uh,
people are found in history because the
one immutable fact of history as human
nature,
like it literally does not change and
you see consistent themes over time.
And so if you want to understand what's
happening,
look backward and you will,
I mean just pretty conventional stuff.
But now it sounds kind of radical,
but I'm basically at.
My main influence was my dad.
I grew up with my dad and my brother.
And again,
his view was,
you know,
just because all the Chin tuggers are
saying it does not prove it.
Does that seem like a pretty obvious
through line to your success right now?
Because it's like every day there is
some other group think exactly.
Lunacy that it's like these people then
go on your show.
And I always think it's hilarious
because it's like,
do they know what they're getting into?
They're going to be a and will,
but they don't actually have the same
goals for the debate that I do.
So I'm linear and literal and old
fashioned and I go into it believing
that I can win the person over with a
superior reasoning or you know,
a larger and more compelling facts set
or whatever they're coming to this
believing they've already won because
they have superior virtue.
So they're having a theological
conversation.
I'm having a political debate and too
often we talk past each other.
That's interesting.
Theological conversation.
A couple,
a couple of people have mentioned on the
show,
my friend Peter,
because he and a philosophy professor
has been on a few times.
He calls this sort of new leftism a
secular religion.
Of course.
Do you view that?
Look,
I'm an Episcopalian,
so I know what happened because the
episcopal church was the church or the
American ruling class,
our national cathedrals and Episcopal
church.
So our culture was rooted in mainline
protestantism.
I mean this was a Protestant country and
our rulers,
whether they were like literally
Protestant or not,
internalized the values of that faith
and then within like a 20 year period,
the faith evaporated.
The Episcopal church barely exists
anymore,
and certainly as a national force it's
irrelevant,
but that didn't eliminate the religious
impulse within people,
which is inherent.
It's innate.
We're born that way.
We worship something in the end whether
you know it doesn't need to be God,
and so they've transferred that
religious impulse to the political
sphere.
They're making the same arguments that
19th century Protestants made,
especially the calvinists like,
I am safe.
Like I know this.
That's my baseline assumption.
I'm one of God's elect.
You were not.
If you go into any conversation like
that,
nothing will be resolved because it's
already been decided.
Well,
it's good.
Verse Evil.
Exactly,
exactly what it is.
Yeah.
Was it always like this?
It wasn't like wha.
What,
what Gimme Gimme some markers of when
you saw things kind of start to change.
I mean,
I'm kind of,
you know,
I'm not an intellectual and a talk show
host,
so I'm a little that we have our promo
clip.
Well,
it's,
it's true.
I mean,
that's what I do.
Um,
so it took me a while to see the
outline.
I mean,
this all comes kind of slowly to me
because I'm caught in an earlier time
just by virtue of my age and so I would
have these conversations that were
confusing to me where you'd be debating
a so called liberal and I would be and I
would find myself taking the liberal
side,
like in favor of free speech or you
might default suspicion of corporate
power or concentrations of power
anywhere because it's a threat to the
individual or in favor of due process or
you know,
I would take a position that I heard
liberals have of my childhood take and
the liberal I'm debating will be like,
nope.
And if Google says that it's true or you
know,
if you're accused,
prove yourself innocent or if what you
say is offensive,
you don't have right to say it and be
like,
wait a second.
This is a mirror image of what I grew up
with.
So actually to answer your question as
honestly as I can,
I don't know if they ever really meant
what they said.
I really don't.
It's possible that the pursuit of power
and the empowerment of the Democratic
Party was always the goal and that was
just the disguise they used in order to
achieve it.
In 1979,
I don't know the answer.
Do you think we'd be in a healthier
situation if there was a same democratic
party even if all the policies were
again and believes?
Yeah,
that's the point in my book.
The funkshway is off,
so for 100 years you had one party which
was the corporate party,
the Republican Party,
the country club party,
the party of the ruling class and the
other party existed.
Ineffective.
Keep it in check and to say,
wait a second,
you know you're getting rich because all
these people are working really hard.
You need to think about their interests
and a bunch of different things happen.
The value of labor dropped because of
technology to the point where it's not
even worth representing the working
class because they're not worth anything
actually that this was the calculation
of the Democratic Party.
And so basically what you have is this
weird alignment where the leadership of
the Republican Party represents
corporate interests and leadership of
the Democratic Party represents
corporate interests and there's no one
to represent the middle class.
And that again,
the balance is off.
You need a vigorous party standing up
and saying,
well wait a second.
You need balance.
Always.
Yeah.
So is that the part of this that sort of
scary for our future.
And that's kind of what you're going for
in the book is that if one side
completely implodes,
which it seems more likely as we're
taping this at the moment,
that the Democrats are.
Yes,
absolutely implode.
That it's not as if all the conservative
policies that you might like would
suddenly take root.
It's that we would actually tilt in some
really bizarre.
Exactly.
That's exactly right.
I mean this is why marriage is an
institution works because there's like
another person pushing back against your
bad instincts are balancing you out.
You know,
and what's true at home is probably true
on a national scale,
on a political scale.
And yes,
you absolutely need a vigorous and
principled opposition party always,
or else you've got something really
ugly.
Then you've got the monitor party,
which is kind of what we have.
You know Jordan Peterson,
who I know you admire also one of the
lines when he's talking about politics,
it's interesting you brought up
marriage.
Hello.
He say,
you know,
it's like a fight with your spouse.
You don't want to beat them because then
you're married to a loser.
You want to give them a chance to figure
out something so that you'll be able to
move forward.
And we seem at this,
we're at this odd place right now where
it's like one side is trying to be the
other side,
the other side of trying to beat the
other side and the rest of us,
which I think is actually most of us are
just like,
that's true,
and you don't want to beat your spouse
because you're married to a loser,
but you're also a loser if you're
married to a loser.
The point is,
you're implicated in the future of the
other side because in the end you're all
in this together.
Even though you're coming from it from
different perspectives,
so you're,
we're all Americans,
so in the same way that crushing your
spouse doesn't actually win you any kind
of meaningful victory or victory you'd
want crushing your fellow Americans,
doesn't improve your life or your
country.
So like,
you know,
you don't want any of this.
It's going to lead to something really
bad action,
really ugly.
And everybody who's paying any kind of
attention senses it on an animal level.
This is,
this is moving in a,
in a really ominous direction.
So I know we could talk about why we're
frustrated with the Democrats all along
and all that,
but let's,
let's put that aside because I feel like
that's a little bit of low hanging fruit
and we both do it.
We do it enough.
So let's,
let's talk more about the Republican.
Yes.
So tell me some of your frustrations
with the Republican Party.
It's really simple.
The Democratic Party was for,
you know,
add probably close to 100 years,
the party of wage earners,
and sometime in the last,
I would say 15 years,
probably at the end of the Clinton,
right,
to kind of apex of the tech boom in the
late nineties,
uh,
the Clinton administration decided to
reorient the party away from its
traditional base to it's new base,
which is the rich and the poor and the
Republican party being dumb didn't see
this.
And it was only the emergence of trump
that forced them to sort of realize
that,
wait a second,
you know,
we don't represent the people we thought
we represented actually the country.
It was the country club party.
They denied it.
They hated that.
That line,
because it was true.
I mean it's,
it's the things that are true that we,
we do,
but we now need to become the
middleclass party.
Well,
they just didn't want to become the
middleclass party actually at all.
And it took trump.
I mean,
trump is a flawed person.
Complex will not a complex person but a
flawed person.
We'll get to that,
but he basically has forced the
Republican party to be what it in effect
already is the party of last resort for
people making,
you know,
50 to $150,000
a year,
you know,
the people who are making enough not to
be on welfare but not enough to send
their kids to summer camp.
That is a.
I mean that's the core of the country
and they don't want to represent those
people and to.
So to me,
and I'm not one of those people,
I'm not here to give you the view from
coal country at all.
I grew up in La Jolla and Georgetown,
so like,
but I know less about what the middle
class things.
I know a lot about what the ruling class
things.
Having lived in it my whole life and
they hate the leadership of the
Republican Party.
Hates the American middle class and has
contempt for them and that's
infuriating.
What does it say though that trump who's
not one of them?
Exactly.
To care about them.
You who's not.
One of them seems to care them.
Me grew up in new.
I've only lived in New York and La.
Yeah,
exactly.
Like what is that?
What?
Why has there been such a shift that
that almost seems impossible to that
trump would be the hero of these people,
but that's exactly the last time we had
something like this.
Of course it was in the progressive era,
Teddy Roosevelt,
really the pivotal president of post
civil war America.
I would argue who made this a capitalist
country by restraining capitalism the,
you know,
the Romanovs didn't do that and they got
70 years bolshevism.
Right.
But Roosevelt,
who really was a genius,
I was like,
wait a second.
The concentration is corporate power.
So scary.
They're gonna overwhelm the democracy
and we're going to have a counter
reaction,
you know,
in the wobblies are going to take power.
So Roosevelt was the last person to fill
this role and he was exactly the same.
Similar to trump.
He wasn't throwing chairs through the
window into the country club.
He was throwing them out onto the street
like he was from the class that he was
trying to restrain.
And you sort of have to be like,
he knew what they were like because he
was one of them.
I don't know,
there's something,
but I would just say my,
for me,
it always goes back to I have greater
sympathy for the lone guy who's getting
pushed around that I do for the group
that's pushing them around.
So I feel like right now the least
popular group in America,
you know,
lives in the middle west and they have
kind of antiquated social attitudes and
they have very little economic power and
they're overweight and everyone hates
them.
And I feel like really because they're
Americans actually like,
you don't.
What is this,
what they were doing this to black
people or Hispanics or any group.
I would be sympathetic because I hate
that.
And I'm actually not even sure that when
it comes to some of the social stuff
that their abuser.
That and I agree,
I think they've changed.
And I think,
I mean I can see this from you would
know,
you would know you.
People don't.
They want you to live however you are.
They don't want you to come on their
property and take their stuff and you
can't punch them walking down the
liberal gay guy from New York.
They're like,
we love,
you know,
I mean,
I totally agree actually,
but in the mind,
in the kind of Cliche,
controlled mind of your average Brooklyn
intellectual,
they're all,
you know,
medieval,
but they're not actually there.
They're basically libertarian and
temperament.
They always have been.
Yeah.
So what is trump then as you've
interviewed the guy a bunch of times?
Yeah.
What actually in the scheme of what your
book is about and sort of where America
is at at the moment,
is he just the great record that we sort
of needed so that this ship of fools
wasn't gonna sink and take everybody a
record.
Look,
here's what trump is not.
Trump is not the guy who comes to
Washington and transforms the system
because he's not capable of that.
He's not interested in that.
Washington is a very specific town.
Okay.
So like the legislative process is
highly complex.
He doesn't understand.
It doesn't seek to.
He's not going to be the guy who runs on
these nine policies and then affects
them once,
select it,
gets them to the congress,
gets them to the agencies he can.
Um,
that's not his role.
It's very frustrating actually.
If you're from DC like me to watch it,
you're like,
wow,
you know what a second get the Energy
Department under control,
not going to happen is $3 million
executive branch employees versus trump
trump's role.
Is that right?
That's that right there.
There's $3,000,000,000,
million.
Three dollars million executive.
I think there are 3 million executive
branch employee that,
that may include the military by the
way,
which was not quite right,
but I'm just saying like the permanent
class in DC and I live right in the
center of them.
You know,
they hate trump.
He's a threat to them,
but why do they hate him?
They hate him.
Not because he's a right winger.
He's hardly right.
We're actually here.
They hate him because he's the guy who
says the obvious things.
So like when we went to Helsinki last
summer and interviewed him during the
Putin thing and like the crystallized
for me in this conversation I had with
him off camera,
I said,
I said something,
I'm asking about NATO.
And he goes,
why don't we have NATO?
And as someone who's looked like a Cold
War Kid,
I was like,
well,
I like NATO.
I'm thinking to myself.
And he goes,
you know,
the Soviet Union,
fell in 1991.
It wasn't the point of Vedo keep them
from invading western Europe but they
don't exist anymore.
Why?
Why do we still have them?
And I'm trying to searching for a good
answer and I couldn't find one.
So trump repeats this and public.
And everyone's like,
well,
shut up.
You know,
what are you working for?
Potent?
And I thought this is what trump does.
He comes in and his kind of artistic way
and ask the obvious question at the core
of whatever the issue is.
That is the one question everyone's been
avoiding because they don't have to
answer to it.
So like,
well why do,
why are we signing a trade agreement and
letting the other signatories ignore the
terms?
Why don't we have a border?
I don't know,
these are not complex questions are very
obvious questions,
but because they are an answered an
unanswerable,
in some cases they exposed shorter the
mediocrity of a ruling class.
Like they actually don't know what
they're doing is the truth.
Right?
So I have a lot of friends.
I think you know,
some of them who think that this thing
that you're talking about with trump is
this sort of existential threat to the
system that this erratic minus this idea
of you just throw the idea out there and
then let it sort of ruminate and see
what happens.
But that is just too dangerous to play
ball with.
I suspect you disagree.
Well,
I don't know.
I mean I don't think you want.
I mean populism is a threat to
everything that we have.
I'm not a populist at all and I think
it's.
But I think populism arises as a symptom
of discontent that you need to address
in a democracy.
If you want to continue the democracy,
so,
um,
I don't want to live in a country this
volatile anymore.
Nobody does,
but I think in order to solve the
problems,
you have to name them.
You know,
I,
I'm not one of these guys it like I
believe in creative destruction.
It's very easy to destroy things,
very hard to build them,
you know,
it's incremental effort over time that
builds things.
So no,
I mean,
look,
I understand the complaint 100 percent,
but I also think it's a two way deal
here.
So if I say,
hey dave,
you know,
like,
did you pay for this house?
And you're like,
that's the one thing I don't want to
talk about because actually you didn't,
you're just squatting here.
Whose fault is that?
I mean,
I guess,
you know,
I'm disruptive for asking you the
question,
but you also should pay for the house.
You delay.
Do you know what I mean?
So like he's calling bs on them.
I get why they don't like it.
But it also is a call to action to them
to like answer the question and rule in
a way that is sensible and wise and
sustainable and they're not.
So the byline on the book.
How is selfish ruling classes bringing
America to the brink of revolution?
Yes.
Do you think we're that close?
I think we're in the middle of it.
We just elected Donald Trump.
President.
What?
I mean.
This is like,
this is what got me to write the book,
like Donald Trump,
who I've known for 20 years and always
sort of liked because we're like,
why wouldn't you?
I think it's just funny as hell.
Did you,
did you ever think he was racist or any,
any of those?
Like put aside the center part.
I mean,
look,
I think on some level everybody is
bigoted.
I mean that's the human heart is dark
and a light and you know,
it's a patchwork.
But like talk about.
I mean look,
if he has a policy,
if he were to get up and say,
you know,
the problem is that this one racial
group is screwing everybody else.
And in response,
we need to crush that,
we need to attack them in public and
then make it much harder for them to get
jobs.
Government contracts get into school.
That would be racist.
Racist.
Oh wait.
That's what our ruling class has been
doing for 35 years.
So,
right.
You want really wanna have a
conversation about racism.
Racism is attacking people on the basis
of their immutable characteristics,
which is like how our government
operates.
It's totally wrong.
Um,
so yes,
there's a lot of racism is trumping
offender.
I probably who isn't,
but the actual structural racism that
hurts people and rewards others on the
basis of their skin color or something I
thought we got rid of 50 years ago that
is not being perpetuated by trump.
It's being perpetuated and defended and
celebrated by his critics.
Don't lecture me or anyone else about
racism if you're pushing that crap.
Isn't that the irony?
It's half the guests that you have on
your show are the people who are
actually trying to inject racism into
the system.
Quotas and the rest of that,
of course,
you know,
why are they doing this?
It's complicated psychological
phenomenon,
but at root it's much easier to maintain
power when you divide your opponents,
when you divide the country into warring
tribes based on characteristics that
don't change and therefore can't be
resolved.
You know,
this is how the British ruled India.
This is the problem with Rwanda.
I mean this is like a very well known
phenomenon,
but anyway.
Yes,
it's all projection and displacement.
It's like whatever I'm doing,
I'm accusing you of doing like,
I can't believe you know,
whatever it is,
and it's in it.
It's actually orwellian because it's not
a lie.
It's the mirror image of the truth.
Yes.
And your.
This is what you're fighting constantly
on your show.
It actually gives you a headache,
like I have a bunch of kids and they lie
because everybody lies and you
especially lied to the people you love
because you care about their opinion.
Most so kids lie to their parents,
like it's a feature of it,
but a child's lie is very recognizable
because it's always three shades off
from the literal truth.
So it's like you a tenorio's no,
I just had three,
but no one's contesting that you ate the
Oreos.
Right.
What they're doing is what all
authoritarian regimes do in Norwell.
Being the great genius and English ever
got right to the heart of it.
He's like,
you know,
if I were dealing with a,
a powerful leftist,
I would say you wait three hours and be
like,
no,
actually you did.
You get the Oreos and I'm going to
punish.
It's like,
what?
No,
that's the.
It's actually much more effective and
manipulative not to grade the truth and
distort the truth,
but to tell the opposite of the truth
because it throws the other person
completely off.
That's been why they hate all of the
supposed minorities who,
who walk away leave.
That's.
There's nothing they hate more than a
gay person.
That leaves a black person.
Really.
An Asian person that leaves.
Yeah.
I can't imagine I have just because of
my job.
I mean I know a lot of people who
dissent from the Orthodoxy within their
group.
Do you know?
Because I try to have them on because I
think they're brave.
Do you know what I mean?
Like I'm not involved in any of these
debates.
I'm so,
but,
but like if you're a gay guy who was
like,
you know what,
I'm not really on board with this.
What happens to you?
It's and I have deep sympathy for my
twitter lately,
but no I haven't.
I would never go there because it upsets
me.
I think in the end the individual has a
right to make up his mind.
You can control what I do.
Okay.
Societies get to do that.
They get to control the behavior of the
people who live with them.
You're not allowed to sleep in a
crosswalk.
Sorry,
we don't allow it.
Fine.
What you can't do is control what I
think that's not allowed.
That crosses the line from order to
totalitarianism and all of a sudden for
the first time in my life,
that's what they are.
Not simply attempting,
but demanding.
Yeah.
So.
All right,
so then that's a perfect segue to the
technological part of this,
because I think the last time I was on
your show,
this is what we discussed.
Just going on with Google.
What's going on with the algorithms are
people be in shadow,
banned,
etc.
Etc.
I think thEre's plenty of evidence that
yes,
this is all real.
What is your solution to this?
I know,
I suspect you don't want the government
coming in and fixing them.
Or Is this a unique case now?
Well,
it's,
I think it's a,
it's an I,
I hate to use the term existential
threat because it's been all and
overused,
but actually it is an existential threat
to the ability of the us government to
run the country to administer the
democracy.
Um,
yeah.
Look,
google.
There are 20,000
engineers,
engineers making between two and
$400,000
working right now just on google search.
Just on that one feature of google,
20,000.
This is the most technologically
advanced and powerful organization in
the history of the world.
It's technology and capabilities so far
outstrip those to the pentagon,
for example,
where the chinese military or the
russian,
the russians or any other group.
This is the most powerful technological
entity in the world which has a
chokehold on all human information in
english.
So that is all sort of all you need to
know.
I don't care if jesus is in charge of
the country.
That's too much power for any entity to
have and it's a,
it's a threat to the nation state
actually.
And it's a threat to all of us.
So yeah,
I think whatever it takes is what we
need to do.
Like now,
is that a tough pill for a conservative?
They don't know.
are you kidding?
Well,
first of all,
I would say not to go to motive.
I hate it when people do that,
but in fact a lot of just flat out
bought off by google.
Google literally funds the antitrust
think tank in Washington.
I'm not speaking for ian.
No,
but look,
no,
but,
but it's so a symmetrical like all these
debates are because with liberals who
are only about power,
you just make the pitch like,
look,
we'll fund you were on your side,
you know,
that we're part of the coalition of the
ascendant.
So just like no problem with
conservatives,
all they who are sort of like dog,
like in the eu market.
You knoW what I mean?
It's like,
what are you against markets you want
government control you for regulation.
I ran and ran and ran.
that conserves and like,
oh my gosh.
Kryptonite.
I'm sorry.
You're right.
You're totally right,
mr google.
It's actually and so I feel like I'm the
only person who like,
yeah,
of course I'm concerned.
Of course I'm not for regulation.
Of course I believe in markets,
but this isn't a free mark.
This is your friend.
This is your version of capitalism.
This is what you've been promising all
these years when like two guys who run a
company,
it's not even american whose values are
not aligned with the interest of my
country is in charge of the country.
No,
I'm not for that.
Sorry I got to say this man.
I did not think that I was going to
bring you in here and that I'd have
tucker carlson agreeing with my friend
eric weinstein about this,
but that you're basically laying out the
same case.
He's lit
big
and and sometimes I think,
well maybe I'm going crazy.
Maybe I'm thinking about this too much
and I'm becoming like the wacko who's
like,
you don't understand us actually.
The deeper.
Yeah.
And I know people who work there and
I've actually spent a lot of time on it
because I'm.
Because I know,
I don't think I'm overstating it.
And by the way,
I'm not temperamentally an extremist.
I'm always.
I'm from southern California,
you know,
I'm a kind of semi observant
episcopalian.
I'm not like now where,
you know,
the end is no,
I am.
That's not the way I am.
But on this topic,
I think I'm becoming that because I
think the facts warranted.
What do you make of the whole shift of,
of what's happening with news and
technology at the moment that,
that.
It's funny,
I said this to you in the green room,
but when I was doing a show,
the peterson last week,
I said,
oh,
you know,
tucker carlson's on my show next week.
The audience went wild,
like,
we're crazy.
And I was like,
oh,
that's interesting because I hear from
so many of these young people that they
don't get their new uh,
from cable news anymore.
I think you and gutfeld are a little bit
of a,
like a bridge sort of between mainstream
and,
and the internet thing,
um,
but that,
that cnn has sort of become a joke that,
that just saying these things about
cable news,
I know that's already the punchline and
I spent many years at cnn and hosting a
show there and had a lot of,
have a look,
have friends there.
I mean the landscape changes technology,
you know,
destroys and creates,
it's a very familiar cycle.
I think cable news has remained relevant
much longer than a lot of us who work in
a thought it would.
But that of course will change because
technically,
once again,
technology changes everything.
What's ominous is the next thing.
I'm completely for digital media.
I owned part of a digital media company,
but we've sort of wound up exactly in
not in the opposite place we expected to
wind up.
I mean the promise was that this was
going to diversify,
you know,
the media and decentralized power over
information.
And of course the opposite,
you know,
the little controls everything.
So without youtube,
I mean where are you with that youtube?
So we're actually fInding ourselves more
dependent upon a smaller group of people
who hate free speech and hate our
values.
That's a very precarious place to be.
Somebody needs to introduce competition
into the space.
Like yesterday,
like right now it's the most important
thing.
Otherwise we're going to find ourselves
like at the mercy of these stars.
Like is that where you want to be?
It's the opposite of where you want to
be.
If only there were some influential
billionaires to be listening to this
show.
We're not going to name names,
but whenever two or more people who
thought thIs through for 10 minutes get
together,
they mentioned one name and they're
like,
why is he coming to save us?
Well now you said it's a heat,
but let's not get lost in gender.
So with that being said about the
technological component watching cable
news shift right now,
there's also an issue that a lot of
people are getting their news from this,
from this show shows like this shapiro
rower,
all of these guys.
That's kind of worrying to at some
level,
right?
And I say that I'm talking about guys
that I love,
but like,
just that,
you know,
the fact checking is different here than
say it would be on cable news.
Not that cable news has done a great
job.
No,
but you're right.
I mean we're part,
you know,
we're,
we're always,
uh,
a point on a continuum and we're,
we're in the middle of a cycle where the
media are being reinvented completely.
And you're right.
I mean,
the problem with individual operators,
solo guys on youtube is they have so
much less to lose than a television
network.
Does that,
the incentives to get the facts right
and be responsible of course,
much lower.
Um,
the problem as you well know better than
anybody is that the media has so
discredited themselves that it's like,
it's so obviously propaganda.
But did you ever think it could be that
bad?
No,
I never did.
Every day I look at a story from cnn or
political and forget buzzfeed and all
those other ones.
I forget the really bad ones,
vox.
and it's like everything you guys are
doing,
every headline and the way every
republican has a picture that they look
awful in the picture.
Democrats look great and like every
little thing,
it's like there
smashing us with it.
They just turned it up to 11.
And I've,
I mean,
I grew up in a media family.
I mean my dad was anchor here in la of
abc and so I,
I have always lived in this world and I
always thought the media are liberal,
but I was totally wrong about that.
They're not ideologues actually their
party people.
That's what I totally missed.
Yeah.
They are loyal to the party.
They feel powerless except as part of a
group that is the main distinction
between left and right in this country.
And so whatever the democratic party's
imperatives are,
they will act on them.
If the demOcratic party invaded Canada
tomorrow and they wouldn't see,
I'm serious,
they'd be like,
you know,
these canadians,
they live among us there.
You know what I mean?
They're a fifth column.
Like they would actually do.
It doesn't matter what the part is,
they will defend it.
Once you understand that,
then it all makes sense.
They feel threatened.
That's the truth in you and people like
you are the main threat to them.
It's not me actually.
I'm on a competing medium,
but in the same medium they are.
They know that their power is epic and
when you feel like you're losing
control,
that's when you tried to assert control.
That's when the most ludicrous
propaganda comes when you feel like,
you know,
oh my gosh,
they're not listening to me.
Right.
But that's the funny part.
Part is I always,
and I tweet this all the time,
it's like if these guys had just been
like pretty bad.
Yeah,
I think it would have been tolerable.
People would have because it had been
happening for so long.
People kind of wooded and have noticed
that maybe they could have got a little
worse than we would have been okay with
it,
but it's like they've just completely
bottomed out and.
Well,
this is one of the criticisms of trump
that has a lot of truth in it.
When people are like,
well,
he's a destroyer.
He destroys everything he touches.
You know,
probably an overstatement,
but he does,
you know,
you get close to you sit and stare at
trump all day and you're going to burn
out your news.
Okay.
You are.
And that's one of those I try to do.
I don't do a show about trump.
I didn't write a book about trump.
I'm not against trump.
I think trump is useful in a truth
teller in some ways,
but,
but the people who obsess about trump
are destroyed and that would include his
opponents,
maybe especially his opponent.
So what would you do to get some of
those people back if they're,
if they are out there now,
the ones that really are overboard on
trump that I haven't,
you know,
I've been able to reach them,
some liberalism,
good lefties and liberals so that,
okay,
we can put a hand out for them.
But for the people that are really
feeling like they're buying all the
nonsense and the skies,
hitler and all of this really,
do you have any technique that
I almost never argue about trump.
I really try not to.
I mean,
the platonic ideal for me of a show is
never mentioning trump because I try to
take the long view.
I mean look,
other shows had different roles,
you know,
everybody sees like his or her specific
tasks,
but I feel like mine is to try to take
the long view,
not easy in the middle of this new
cycle.
Of course I get caught up all the time
and the,
you know,
the bullshit of the day,
but,
but I really try to think about like,
well how would this look 10 years from
now?
Like,
trump Will be gone.
I'll be gone.
We'll all be gone because we actually
die at the end.
It turns out so.
But I want the country to 10 years for
10 years.
But I'm just saying,
what kind of country do you want?
That's the question.
Do you want to live in a place where the
individual has the right to dissent?
And I think most people would say yes,
I do.
Yeah.
Is that why the free speech stuff has
become so important to you?
Because I think that it's foundational.
I mean,
that's just if they can tell you what to
say,
they can control what you think and if
they can control you,
think you're not fully human and so
you're really.
You're not fIghting for a political
party or an ideology or fighting for
your humanity.
I believe that that's what I was taught
as a child by liberals and they were
right and I bought it then by the way,
and so the acl used to the for
clearance.
Brandon berg,
who Is not only at literally a clansman
from Ohio,
but a moron like a literally a moron.
He was the least appealing person ever
and they stick their entire credibility
and defending this guy,
why they do that.
They did it,
of course,
to preserve the absolute right of free
speech for the rest of us and they made
the country better.
When you abandon that,
yeah,
dude,
it's over
and now you see what comes out of the
aco and you're like,
you're not.
You're not defending free speech.
You're clearly a progressive group.
They're opposing statements saying,
no,
some speeches is to offensive.
Really because you defended the right of
nazis to march through skokie,
which everyone forgets had the highest
percentage of holocaust survivors of any
town like outside Israel.
Yeah,
I mean it was the most offensive thing
you could do and they defended it and
they lost a lot of money doing it.
Like they lost a ton of donations doing
it,
but they defended the principal and I
noticed you've got nadian strauss's book
we talked about here.
So there are people like her are
dershowitz are these former clu board
members who were like totally bewildered
by this,
not because we care about the acl.
You as an institution who cares and some
dumb nonprofit because the principles
are literally foundational.
Yeah.
All right,
so let's,
let's jump back for just a second here.
So I want to talk about fox generally.
Yeah.
So first off,
you guys are doing something right and I
don't mean just you hear clearly,
if you look at the ratings,
I just looked at this thing and it's
like the last,
bottom 20 shows are all cnn.
The top 10 are basically all fox.
Maybe there's one msnbc show in there
beyond just you.
What,
what do you think that fox is?
Just do it all right.
You know,
being slightly different.
I mean,
I,
you know,
I would argue that the,
I mean I can only speak for my shot.
I'm only in charge of an hour of the,
of 24,
but you know that it's actually worth
defending the principles as distinct
from the individuals or the political
figures in overtime.
Like you're not embarrassed to do that.
It's worth doing,
but I think as a business matter and
just sort of a matter of life if you're
the guy who's not entirely with the herd
and you're like,
actually no,
it's a little bit different,
you know,
you go to the 19 other stores when you
can buy this one product and I've got a
different product.
I mean why is that bad?
Yeah.
So that just seems obvious.
That's just human nature is how
offensive that is.
It's like fog and I've worked,
I've worked at cnn,
I've worked at msnbc,
I worked at pbs,
I worked at esquire.
I'm and I've worked at like a million
different liberal publications and
television channels and they're all
selling exactly the same product and
then there's fox in the mainstream
landscape that's different.
Just one channel is different and the,
the feeling overwhelming feeling is that
should not be allowed.
Like I can't believe that they're
allowed to say what they're saying.
We need to shut them down.
Well that's
the irony.
It's like you guys are the only ones
that will put me on.
I will gladly go on cnn or msnbc,
get on those channels.
I've never been asked.
I can't just show up there and bang on
the door,
but you guys call me and nobody.
Every time I've done your show,
it's alive.
I never know what you're going to ask.
And,
and same thing with some of the other
shows and it's like I will go where I
can talk to people.
I don't want to be edited and
misrepresented,
which.
So I don't know that I would trust a lot
of these other.
No.
Okay.
So that sort of.
But it's just so uninteresting.
I mean,
if everybody's saying,
repeating the exact same pieties
diversity is our strength,
our children,
our future,
whatever this sort of banality is that
you think is profound.
If everybody is saying the exact same
thing,
like this is boring.
I like to have.
I like to have people on who surprised
me.
Like what?
Do you know what I mean like that.
Just because again,
I'm more curious.
I mean I'm a human being.
I,
I want to think about things.
Does it ever drive you crazy to just be
in the,
in the constraints of what television
is?
Because we've done segments where it's
like,
you know,
we've got maybe six minutes and I feel
like I just started and then yoU're
like,
robin,
I'll See you next time.
You know?
Yeah.
I mean I was a writer before I went into
tv and one of the reasons that I failed
a couple of times pretty spectacularly
and tv is because I didn't understand
the medium and I didn't respect it.
I was like,
I'm a writer,
I'm a deep person.
Here I am in the shallow medium.
And what I didn't understand is it tv
is,
it's completely,
it's a different thing and it's got its
own requirements and its own rules and
you need to understand what it's capable
of and is capable of great things.
It's just not capable of everything.
You know what I mean?
It's not capable of explaining concepts,
complex concepts,
just that's not what tv is about.
Someone was for.
Is it odd to you that the interview,
the real long form this like just sit
down with another human being that,
you know,
cnn booted Larry King,
which I think was the beginning of the
end for them.
So smart.
I think that I really believe it.
I mean I've never heard anybody else say
that,
but I argued that when I worked there.
yeah.
So,
so you were.
Because they were getting rid of him.
I think he told me he was here a couple
of weeks ago.
He said,
I thought it was the number one rated
show is still on the network.
it was number two at the time.
And they said,
no,
we're done 30 years.
Adios.
Right.
And they also ended crossfire,
which had become a kind of perversion of
its former self,
but I was in both versions of it and at
one point crossfire was like a public
service,
you know,
to sort of equally matched,
did something shift with crossfire
because I do remember watching you on
crossfire and watching those guys.
And it was so it became partisan,
which is Uninteresting.
Nobody wants to hear what your team
thinks.
We already know what's interesting is
when we throw up an idea or a policy and
we deconstructed and we have two fairly
evenly matched people,
you know,
kind of competing for,
you know.
So anyway,
it became something much more.
But the idea was aLways a good idea.
And especially the idea of Larry King,
I pitched that show too many different
channels,
black curtain to people,
our lonG conversation.
And my argument was this will rate
people want this,
there's none of it.
And everyone's like good Things.
So we need to interstitials in graphics.
And it's like they love interstitial.
It's unbelievable.
And now,
of course with youtube,
it's like you look at the numbers that
you're getting and others are getting
with that exact format and they're huge.
It turns out,
yeah,
of course there's a market for that.
Why wouldn't there be,
how much of all of this?
Everything we're discussing here and so
much of what you're doing on your show
is just that people are just tired of
having their intellect insulted.
Totally,
completely.
We'll look at television versus movies.
If you had told me 30 years ago that the
most interesting,
you know,
visual art being created would be in
television,
scripted television.
Like what?
I don't think so that's the province of
moron,
like full house.
But um,
but it turned out to be true because to
stand up for bob saget,
bob saget,
but she's actually very smart.
But the point is that there is,
especially when we're all narrow
casting,
when you don't need to reach,
you know,
$80,
million people when you can reach 3
million.
And that is a more than viable
commercial proposition.
You can aim at an audience that wants
that.
And there is a substantial audience that
does.
Yeah.
Okay.
So fox news,
we get it.
Some things are clearly going right and
by ratings and everything else.
Is there anything that fox is doing that
you think is wrong?
Is he too close to the or or anything?
You know,
I,
I mean,
I mean I'm obviously I'm dodging the
question.
Even if I had a real answer,
I would run from that question because I
worked there.
I have to ask you a hundred.
Right?
But if I'm being completely honest,
no,
I'm not a huge.
I'm so caught up in our hour and I'm so
it's such a hive in my show and we have
like,
you know,
I intentionally hired really smart,
smarter than I am people that I don't
have a sense sometimes of the larger
programming.
I would say as a general matter,
I've always tried not to be aligned with
any politician because in the end,
no matter how sympathetic it might be to
the message,
it's a politician and I'm not.
If I wanted to be a policy maker I would
be one because it's a pretty low bar for
that.
It turns on certain sound.
Right?
Exactly.
So do you ever think about it?
Not for two seconds.
I would never want.
I mean,
I live in that world so I know what it
is.
I don't want that.
I have a journalist temperament.
I like to watch.
I like the freedom to say what I really
think is true.
I don't want one thing I will say about
fox,
which I am grateful for every single day
and this is rupert murdoch.
They don't,
they do not control what you say.
I've had this show for two years,
almost exactly two years.
Not a single time of someone called you
or no one calls me at all,
but like no one calls in is like,
I can't believe you said there's nothing
like that.
Pure editorial freedom.
So like why is that not a great job?
Yeah.
No,
I mean I know it.
Again,
I just want to illustrate because people
don't understand that every time I've
Gone on your show that we,
you know,
they give you some sense of what we're
going to talk about and that's it.
We go live,
it's live and if you want to say
something insane like we can't stop you.
Yeah,
you know,
and,
and I would say the other thing is the
way tv works,
at least at our network,
but I think this is true.
When I worked at the others,
it was also true.
The shows have enormous autonomy.
They really do.
I mean there's not a morning call where
it's like here's our line on this or
that or the other.
It's like I never talked to any.
I talked to my executive producer,
Justin wells,
whom I love and a lot of my other
producers all morning and just in the
car parked outside.
I was just doing a show like here's what
I think we should do.
There's,
I mean we can do whatever we want.
Yeah.
What,
what's your day to day like over there?
So I know what it's like to do.
I do a couple shows a week and I'm doing
long form and this way,
but we're not doing a zillion segments
and all and all the interstitials and
all that stuff.
What's your sort of day to day?
Tucker wakes up,
he's got to show that night.
Yeah,
I mean I try and I'm married.
I've been married for 27 years.
I really liked my wife.
My kids are all Gone,
so I really try and stay home.
I mean,
the key in daily tv is not to go insane.
That actually is like the whole deal
right there.
If you can keep from becoming an
insecure sort of bag of neuroses,
um,
do you mean that just because of the
media criticism and just constant
worrying about ratings and all of that,
but just the medium itself leaves most
anchors at some point feeling totally
exposed and alone it's like I'm out
here,
you know,
I've got a staff of 80 people or
whatever,
but in the end I'm out here to.
IT's just me.
I'm taking all the crap and no one's
backing me up.
I mean,
every person in the business feels that
way at a certain point.
And then you start to feel like,
you know,
no one understands.
You know what I mean?
And you actually become so self pitying
and self-involved that no matter how
much they pay you,
your deeply unhappy and then you start
acting erratic ways and like look at tv
and you know exactly who's going through
this,
right?
Everybody except me,
because I keep my world's so small when
I married my high school girlfriend,
I live walking distance from my dad and
my brother and my college roommate and
best friend and that's who I talked to
everyday,
everyday.
And uh,
and the reason I do that is because I
love them,
but also because I don't want to feel
the way that most people on tv do I
want,
I want to talk to people I love and
trust and,
and I want my security and happiness to
come from those relationships.
And not from the affirmation I get on
television because you will become a
crazy person.
Someone once said to me,
the head of a tv network when said,
what do you think my job is?
I said,
I don't know,
running a tv network.
And he goes,
no,
it's keeping millionaires from killing
themselves.
My job.
And yet,
how dark is that?
It's also true.
It's like his job was to keep the people
from going totally bananas because the
medium itself drives you crazy and
you're doing this.
No booze,
no cigarettes anymore.
Right?
You got any advice?
The booze is easy.
Drinking coffee,
drink problem,
you know,
I drink a lot.
Voltaire,
levels of coffee.
Not quite as impressive effects,
but yeah,
like quit smoking four or five years
ago.
And,
but I'm,
I'm,
you know,
I wouldn't call it advice,
but I'm a,
I'm an enthusiastic user of nicotine gum
and the lozenges because I think they
really have improved my life like a lot.
I think.
I mean,
I don't want to endorse the product.
Sure.
What the downside is of using nicotine.
There's a huge downside from smoking.
Of course the target gives you cancer
and emphysema.
But,
uh,
I don't think that we've shown that
nicotine for people who don't have blood
pressure problems and I don't.
I'm hurts you.
And I think there's a lot of evidence
that that's great.
Yeah.
Alright,
so I want to spend the remaining time
really focusing on the book.
We sort of did,
I think we did everything we did
everything else,
but let's really focus in on the book.
Okay.
If,
if we're on the brink of a revolution,
what are your prescriptions to say?
But I mean,
I think the first thing you need to do
is cool the temperature a little bit.
presidents not good at that.
That's not his by temperamentally.
He's incapable of doing that.
I don't think he sees it as an important
thing to do.
So is that,
do you think the fundamental sort of,
if we're looking at this just at a,
at a base level,
that,
that trump's temperament and the way the
media is with him,
is that sort of the root of everything
else?
The volatilities,
the problem.
I mean I,
I think that we needed to awaken the in
charge,
not simply of our political system but
also of our economy and our culture from
their suPer,
you know,
hey,
you're not listening.
We're going to let this orange guy to
wake you up.
I actually think that was a useful thing
and necessary thing,
but repeated cycles of political
volatility like break your country.
Obviously there's a million examples of
this and it's obvious,
so um,
you need to calm people down in the main
way you calm people down as the way you
come,
children down,
which is you explained to them as simply
and Clearly as you can,
why?
What's happening is happening while
you're making these decisions and you
give them some sense that they have some
control,
total control,
but some control over the decisions that
you're making,
you know,
you and franchise.
Then we bring them in.
In a democracy,
you need,
you need to mean the system is
predicated on the idea.
So you need to say to people,
look,
you know,
you want x,
y,
and z,
you will elected this guy to build a
wall.
We think a wall is stupid.
We don't think it's going to work.
We think it's kind of embarrassing
actually.
It doesn't matter.
We're going to do it because you have
demanded it.
You have to kind of give people a sense
that the democRacy,
Israel,
if they think it's fake,
they think it's really an oligarchy
posing as a democracy.
What are they going to do?
You don't want to think about that.
so just practice democracy a little bit.
Would calm things down a lot.
Is anyone doing it better than us?
Like for all the sort of anger at each
other right now.
And it's funny because,
you know,
I spend time on twitter wheRe it seems
like the civil war has begun already and
then I get out there in real life and
I'm on this tour and it's like I need
thousands of people all across the
middle of the country who are wonderful
and open and decent and all those
things.
Um,
but I lost my question in that.
What was the point of that?
I mean,
is it actually as bad as it seems and as
anyone,
any other country more stable,
unhappier than ours.
So that was it.
Yeah.
Is there an example to look at?
Because I see all these people always
complaining and as you said,
it's easier to break things and burn
them down than it is to build.
So all these people are always,
oh,
look at these countries.
Look aT the end.
They always look at the nordic
countries.
That seems to be a big one.
Look at that.
Sweden and you know,
even though sweden's got all sorts of
problems right now,
you're one of the only people covering
it.
Actually.
Um,
I'm one of the only swedes on
television.
Maybe that's why you swedish.
My name is carl said.
Oh,
alright,
there you go.
I've got a lot of ikea.
I'm not in any meaningful sense.
Swedish.
I mean,
I guess I am genetically swedish stuff
like even care about that stuff.
One,
1000,
24.
But those are not models.
We can replicate for obvious reasons.
It's a country of Sweden.
Sweden's got 8 million people go tell me
something like that.
Anyway,
uh,
know who does it?
Look,
nobody does it better.
There's no greater country.
I don't have a foreign passport.
I'm stuck here.
I plan to do everything I can for the
country because I have a longterm
interest in it and I don't want to move
anywhere else.
I can't think of anywhere.
Better helpline.
Switzerland is pretty nice,
but there's no humor allowed.
So I probably the anyway,
the point is,
um,
no,
you can look at countries and see their
ruling classes doing things you,
ours did.
There's no country.
I kind of despise more than China.
But one thing I do admire about China is
that its ruling clique a thinks long
term about stability.
That's their overriding concern.
Now,
of course,
that's rooted in their desire to hold
onto power,
which is ignorable.
I get it.
But they understand how important
continuity and stability are to the
site.
So they think deeply and they don't make
the right decisions all the time.
Obviously the one child policy is a
disaster,
but they,
that's how they think.
And I wish we thought that way.
I think we've to internalized
libertarian economics as a model for
everything that like it's always
virtuous to destroy this thing and build
something new and we don't understand is
like that's not.
People are not capable of that at scale.
Like 325 million people can't deal with
tearing down in remaking the society.
Every generation.
They just can't.
They'll go crazy.
And so we need to identify the things
that we want to preserve and actively
work to preserve them.
And,
and I would start with the bill of
rights.
So
I think any of the people right here,
these beautiful character caricature is
maxine waters and mitch mcconnell and
nancy pelosi.
Who else do we have on there?
I'm upside down.
Hillary clinton.
Bill crystal,
crystal river bayzos.
Who's this?
I'm upside down here.
That's lindsey.
Lindsey graham.
Oh well,
okay.
So I actually wanted to sort of get
lindsey into this somehow.
He's a little punchier there than in
real life.
Um,
he's become sort of like a,
like a star said like what do you make
of sort of these republicans that like
even mitch mcconnEll,
like they seem like they've got a little
juice at the moment.
It's like the cabinet thing did
something.
Well,
they did the right thing and they're on
the cover of my book,
not because of that or any real
political reason.
Particularly lindSey graham is there and
it's described inside.
He's the embodiment.
And I like lindsey graham and I think
he's smart,
but he's the embodiment of a phenomenon
that I think is really destructive,
which is the refusal of people to learn
from the failures that they created.
And so like it's okay to have supported
the invasion of Iraq.
I did.
What's not okay is to seven,
10,
15 years later,
look at it and be like,
no,
that wasn't a mistake.
And no,
I refuse to learn from what happened.
And yes,
I think we should do it again like that.
That's something for which you should be
held responsible.
that's my only point.
It's like I catch my kid's doing
something wrong.
I'm not surprised that they did
something wrong,
but I demand that they can see they did
something wrong and I make them try and
learn from it.
Like that's just basic.
alright,
so let's do a.
I know there's nothing that people in
television like doing more than
predictions.
We got an election coming on,
like accountability is the problem.
All right.
So you seem pretty open to this.
So,
uh,
look,
I,
I had Glenn Beck on last week.
How was he?
He was great.
He was [inaudible].
This is a guy who,
if you haven't sat down with them and
how you.
Oh,
okay,
good.
Like this is a guy who admits freely now
that he was part of the problem,
that he was one of the people that led
to the polarization and he's trying to
fix it.
Yes,
I can,
you know,
people will say,
well,
his motives,
he Just wants whatever money it.
It's like people's.
Yeah.
And I don't want to attack people.
Yes.
If you repeatedly show me that your
motives are bad,
but I see a guy who genuinely
ingredients trying to fix some things.
Um,
so when I discussed this with him about
the midterms,
we sort of agreed basically that the
only option that I see that is remotely
possible here for the betterment of the
country going forward,
the democrats kind of have to be
destroyed so that they can rebuild.
I don'T otherwise,
if they do well in these midterms,
we ended up in two years of impeachment.
And then it's like that,
that revolution thing that you think
we're on the brink of.
I agree with that.
And the reason is not because trump is
inconvenienced or in peachtree or
whatever the reason is that the problems
that led to trump's ascent are
unaddressed.
I mean,
that's,
you know,
the,
the dying of the middleclass is the core
problem and no one is talking about it.
And trump,
I have to say sometimes makes it easier
not to talk about it because he seeks to
be the person people talk about anyway,
you know,
the problem.
Um,
yeah.
I mean,
I think the ideas need to be repudiated
really clearly.
Like you don't win when you say that the
guilty have an obligation to prove their
innocence.
I'm sorry.
We're not rewarding that.
Yeah.
What was that?
The ultimate like sort of just obvious
way this all was going to go like
everything with identity,
politics and everything else and believe
all women or because when you group
everybody,
you can't have anybody that wanders.
So the cabinet thing really was kind of
the like,
did it seem obvious to you?
It seemed obvious to me.
That's what it felt like.
The way the reaction
are really obvious.
And I mean,
I got caught up,
I mean,
I say it's obvious,
but I also got caught up as I always do
in my sort of literal like,
but wait a second,
what about ted kennedy or whatever,
when I should have been far more
sophisticated,
just said,
yeah,
what you just said,
which is of course they're doing this
because they have to do it.
And this is kind of the logical apogee
of identity politics anyway,
that no one is really human.
We're all just sort of component parts
of a larger whole of the group.
And we have to act as a member of a
group that can never act alone.
Um,
you know,
our,
our unique humanity cannot be
acknowledged.
I mean,
you must,
you,
yeah,
you must deal with this all the time.
Yeah,
I mean,
I'm like straight white men,
so like,
you know,
whatever.
I guess I'm acting according to type,
but if you're not,
you know,
so anyway,
you know what I'm talking about.
It's yes.
And I should have known that of course.
But the point is,
I don't think that most people buy that
or want to buy.
They don't want to live in that country
where you're required by your dna to act
a certain way.
like what?
So what makes you different from a robot
at that point?
And these are the exact people who are
now defending Elizabeth Warren,
of course,
could not be more fraudulent in which.
Have you had any.
HAve you had a native american tribes?
Men are,
but yeah,
I mean I have to say I think that story
for me has been a happy respite from all
this heavy stuff because it's just so
hilarious.
Oh yeah.
How did for Joseph Smith is warren is.
But I do think there's a deep question
at the bottom of it.
Not even at the bottom,
at the very top of it,
which is like,
should your dna determine your life?
And maybe I'm just too american or too
California or something,
but no,
I don't think it should.
I don't think you're responsible for
what people you never met.
I think you're responsible for the
decisions that you make.
I don't think we Should hurt you because
if your eye color or your height or your
race,
I mean like if,
if you start to accept that it's okay to
inflict group punishment on groups then
like I mean,
isn't that the whole lesson of the 20th
century that that's wrong and that's a
culdesac that ends in bloodshed.
Yes.
So why are we accepting this and
everyday on tv,
one of the main pros,
last thing I'll say,
but one of the main problems with our
coverage is that as brought to us by
dumb people and I really think finance
the whole finance world is partly to
blame.
Forty years ago,
like smart evan thomas from newsweek
lives used to live on my street.
I've been.
Tom is a very smart guy,
went to harvard,
you know,
he's kind of liberal,
whatever,
but he's in legitimately smart,
smarter than I am.
He left harvard and went to work at
newsweek because that was kind of an
acceptable path.
Now what percentage of harvard seniors
are going to newsweek now?
They're going into private equity.
So what you're Left with,
it's almost,
it's almost like medieval england where
the,
you know,
under private jennifer,
the first son gets the estate and the
second son has to like figure it out or
become an army officer,
a vicar or something.
It's like we're getting the dumb people
were getting the people who can't think
for themselves or all of a sudden
winding up as cable news anchors.
It's like,
what?
Do you know what I mean?
I do know what you mean.
That's why I'm on youtube with all the
smart people have youtube,
you know what I mean?
Listen.
And you know,
the first video that I did in uh,
in 2018 was that I thought this was
going to be the year of unusual
alliances.
And I would say I would say this is
right up there because I,
I consider this a great alliance and I
think you're doing great work and all
that stuff.
Not that you need
any body,
that it's really simple.
If you,
if you feel a moral obligation to scream
at people in restaurants,
if you disagree with their political
views,
you're not on my side.
and if you don't,
you are so it's like,
I don't even know what I mean.
This is such an intense moment.
It's thrown everything into stark
relief.
I just care about aligning myself with
people who believe in the individual and
freedom of expression.
Period.
I hear you brother.
And for more on tucker,
watch your mind,
tucker carlson tonight at 8:00
PM eastern on fox news.